prepare for a reaction to Arizona
attorney general Mark bronovich and
Texas Attorney General
Ken Paxton two attorney generals
appreciate you both joining us tonight I
always start with Ken Paxton here and
talk about that situation in Texas I
mean this one's caught on tape but this
type of crime is happening more often
than just the one incident that was
caught by Fox
and you're right unlike Joe Biden I've
been to the Border many times I've
talked to ranchers Farmers all along the
Texas border
people are terrified because their
property is being damaged their fences
are being cut their cattle are being let
loose people are breaking into their
houses they're stealing their their cars
and trucks they don't feel safe with
their children this is a common
occurrence along the Texas border and
I'm sure it's also a common occurrence
all along the border of Arizona New
Mexico and California and it's
unfortunate that this President doesn't
seem to care and doesn't even have the
time to meet with any of these people
that have suffered tragic consequences
as a result of his policies
yeah the president hasn't met with those
people he won't even meet with the
border patrol for goodness sake uh
attorney general bronovich explained
from the Arizona perspective what you're
seeing and and if you can't get into the
whole idea of bussing and what the
administration is doing to move people
outside of Arizona Texas and other
states to other parts of the country
Jason there is crazy there's insane and
there's what Joe Biden has done in our
Southern border I mean I think what his
actions demonstrate is that he's ready
for a different type of Asylum because
the reality is is every state is a
border state 50 percent of the fentanyl
flowing into this country now is flowing
through our Arizona border in the past
two months enough fentanyl has been
seized to kill potentially the entire
population of a state like Louisiana
where our friend and colleague Jeff
Landry is so this is an unprecedented
crisis and every single day there's
about 2 000 godaways uh you know people
that are bringing illegal drugs and
crime into our country and so when I see
somebody like Governor Abbott sending a
few thousand migrants to places like
Martha's Vineyard or you know to
Washington DC you see the left all these
human cries about what a catastrophe it
is but meanwhile places like Yuma
Arizona have tens of millions of dollars
unreimbursed health care costs in places
like Arizona and Texas we are spending
10 tens of millions of dollars on
incarceration costs there's cost to our
education system and of course you
cannot break the law your First Act
entering the country breaking law
undermines the very principles of the
rule of law and why people want to come
to this country in the first place so
what Joe Biden has done is unnecessary
unwise and it's unconstitutional and
that's why we continue to assume
yeah look this is these are policies
that are put in place by the Biden
Harris Administration in action these
are the consequences of the changes that
they made attorney general Paxton Texas
I mean it's just taken the brunt of this
I heard the mayor of Denver complaining
that they had about a thousand migrants
and they were under an emergency you
know declaration but Texas is dealing
with this and Arizona is dealing with
this by by numbers that are so
astronomical I can't even fathom
yeah day one Joe Biden announced that he
was not going to deport people we've now
sued him I think 11 times over
immigration issues and the reason is
he's violating his own constitutional
role to enforce immigration law and the
consequences are not surprising he's
known exactly what he was going to get
and we've gone from really good numbers
under the Trump Administration and from
following federal law to basically
ignoring federal law and ignoring his
duty as president to enforce his his uh
federal federal laws and the problem is
we're all suffering the consequences and
it's not going to be just Texas and
Arizona I promise you this as this as
more and more people come as Millions
cross the border we're all going to be
affected and Mark's right this is not
just uh border states we're all going to
become border states and we're all going
to pay for this not just in in costs but
also in Lost lives and in higher crime
and that's the issue attorney general
bronovich is the Biden Harris
Administration they're not enforcing the
current law and the exacerbating the
problem because these people are being
invited into this country but then once
they get here what are they supposed to
do for food and shelter and jobs and
everything else they're just expect a
handout I mean what else are they going
to do they're here illegally
just to put this in perspective you know
we throw these numbers out there I mean
there's a record amount of people dying
of drug overdoses in this country
especially fentanyl because the cartels
have seized Southern control of our
border I was a gang prosecutor for years
Jason and it breaks my heart to see what
Joe Biden has done in secretary majorcus
in seeding control of our Southern
border the cartels they're making record
profits they're undermining
destabilizing Mexico and we're all
paying the cost and once again we've
talked about this before but the the
number of apprehensions of people on the
terror watch list are once again record
amounts of people so America is is less
safe as a result of the Biden
Administration policies and really it
starts with just a simple enforcing the
law as it is look I'm a first generation
American I understand why people want to
come here but when you undermine the
rule of law when you undermine the
Constitution you essentially eradicate
and destroy the very reason why people
want to come to America and until Joe
Biden cares more about Middle America
that he does a South American Central
America this problem will not go away
and it is a catastrophe it's a man-made
disaster and we are less safe as a
result of Joe Biden
well I think they're doing it on purpose
I think the Democrats know exactly what
they're trying to do because I could
just hear him making the argument at
some point they're going to say oh well
there's so many people here we can't
Deport them how would you Deport all
these people well you invited them here
and they need to be deported uh
gentlemen attorney general uh Paxton
Attorney General bronovich have a happy
new year thanks for joining us hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else